despite its religious veneer Islam can
easily be defined and understood by one
non-religious word tribalism this is key
the entire appeal of Muhammad's call to
the Arabs of his time lay in its perfect
compatibility with their tribal Moray
three in particular loyalty to one's
tribe enmity for other tribes and raids
on the latter to enrich and empower the
former
for 7th Century Arabs and later tribal
and pastoral peoples such as the Turks
and tatars or Mongols who also found
natural appeal in and converted to
Islam the tribe was what humanity is to
Modern
people to be part of the tribe was to be
treated
humanely to be outside the tribe was to
be treated inhumanely
period Muhammad reinforced this ancient
dichotomy of tribalism but by
prioritizing religion over
relatives thus in his constitution of
Medina which he promulgated with various
non-muslim tribes in 622 he asserted
that quote a Believer shall not slay a
Believer for the sake of an unbeliever
nor shall he Aid an unbeliever against a
Believer moreover all Muslims were to
become quote friends one to the other to
the exclusive illusion of Outsiders
unquote hence the umah which is often
translated as Muslim nation was born
emologic connected to the word mother um
the umah came to signify the Islamic
super tribe a sort of universal tribe
that trans sends racial National and
linguistic barriers encompassing any and
all who identify as Muslims and its
natural enemies remained everyone
outside of it again this is basic
tribalism 1.0 though as mentioned with a
religious covering or
veneer or consider the Islamic doctrine
of which I talk about often which is
translated as loyalty and enmity or love
and hate Muhammad preached it and the
and the Quran command it taken together
for example Quran 5822 and 64 call on
all Muslims to renounce and disown their
non-muslim relatives quote even if they
be their fathers their sons their
brothers or their nearest Kindred end
quote and to feel only enmity and hatred
for them until they believe in Allah
alone that is until they become Muslim
check out those verses sometime assuming
your English Quran translation is an
honest one anyway those two verses Quran
58:22 and 6 4 are referring to a number
of Muhammad's close companions who
According to Islamic history renounced
and eventually slaughtered their own
non-muslim relatives as a show of their
loyalty to Allah Muhammad and the
Believers examine I cir's tap of Surah
Al muad verse 22 this Ayah was revealed
during the bad robbery when abua killed
his own
father likewise Abu Bakr ass sidik the
first rightly guided kff almost kill his
non-muslim son ABD rman similarly musab
bin omay is said to have slain his
brother ubid bin omay while Umar
reportedly killed one of his relatives
additionally figures such as Hamza Ali
and Ida bin alh harith also took the
lives of close family members for more
on Alat see my 60-page translation of Dr
am alah's Trea on this Doctrine in my
2007 book the al-Qaeda
reader at any rate from here we come to
the natural origin of jihad tribalistic
Blood Ties were exchanged for religious
ones thereby dividing the world into two
Mega
tribes the Believers in one tent and
their natural enemies the non-believers
or infidels in another and as we've seen
the essence of tribalism is Waring and
praying on other tribes in order to
empower your own this dichotomized world
view is actually enshrined in Islamic
law or shar's mandate that Islam the
Abode of Islam or the world of Islam
must battle Dar Al the Abode of non-
Islam in perpetuity until the former
subjugates the
[Applause]
latter in for example the Encyclopedia
of Islam we read under the entry for
Jihad that quote the spread of Islam by
arms is a religious Duty upon Muslims in
general Jihad must continue to be done
until the whole world is under the rule
of Islam Islam must completely be made
over before the doctrine of jihad can be
eliminated in other words the doctrine
of jihad Warfare on the other is so
pivotal to Islam that without it Islam
ceases to
be this is the path of blood that we
have chosen
we will complete our Jihad Journey to
the
[Music]
End Islam's apotheosis or deification of
tribalism also explains why tribal
societies other than the Arabs also
gravitated to and found Islam appealing
consider the turkic people's oldest epic
the book of d corut although newly
converted to Islam the Turks of this
epic regularly engage in Pagan practices
banned by Islam they eat H meat drink
wine and other fermented drinks and
their women are in comparison to Muslim
women relatively free and independent
it's only in the context of raids on the
other on the Infidel a smooth and easy
transition from raids on the tribal
Outsider that Islam finally becomes
evident in their lives here for example
is a typical pre-battle boast from the
Turks of the Epic
I shall raid the bloody infidels land I
shall cut off heads and spill blood I
shall make the Infidel vomit blood I
shall bring back slaves and slave
girls here is another typical account of
these new Turkish converts Pi exploits
quote they the early Turk converts
destroyed the infidels Church they
killed its priests and made a Mosk in
its place they had the call to prayer
proclaimed they had the invocation or
the shahada recited in the name of Allah
Almighty the best of the hunting birds
the purest of stuffs the loveliest of
girls they selected aside from praying
on the Infidel other which already came
natural to the pre-islamic Turks any and
all nonviolent aspects of Islam fasting
zakat pilgrimage are totally absent from
the lives of these earliest turkic
converts as portrayed in the book of
dedi
corut we the Turks take the most
practical route to Heaven okay you can
go ahead and do fasting zakat Haj and
whatever else but you'll still end up in
hell but if I skip all of that and focus
on Jihad then I'm guaranteed heaven
whether I live or
die even so the older Muslim peoples the
Arabs and Persians praise the new
converts simply because well they fight
in the way of Allah waging Jihad against
the infidels so that's good right being
committed to the Jihad has always gone a
long way to exonerate otherwise unlam
Behavior among Muslims as if one group
of Muslims is well yeah at least they're
doing the hard part war on infidels so
give them a break embraced Islam the
tatars as the Dominican frier roldo who
died in 1320 and who spent about a
decade in the Muslim World once observed
tatars had adopted Islam because it was
the easy religion as Christianity was
the hard one for those love to plunder
as a way to earn a living choose Islam
okay Prophet Muhammad did the same and
it is permitted by Allah you need to
understand that we embraced Islam
because it offers the best way to make a
living by plundering and robbing the
infidels to please Allah that's the key
point in other words whereas Islam
complemented their pre-existing tribal
way of living including by giving them
license to pray on all Outsiders
Christianity only ch challenged
it so it is that Muhammad's most
enduring contribution to world history
is that in repackaging the tribal mores
of 7th Century Arabia through a
theological Paradigm he also deified
tribalism into a sort of hypert
tribalism causing it to outlive its
historic setting and dramatically spill
into the modern era hence the notorious
resistance to assimilation in the west
the creation of B claves and clannish
noo zones in Europe and the constant FL
outs of hate crimes and terrorism
whereas many world civilizations have
been able to break away from or at least
temper their historic tribalism this has
not been and cannot be so easy for Islam
for Muslims to break away from tribalism
is for them to break away from Allah's
laws that's just not possible if Allah
wants us to be primitive forever then so
be it